My name is
Allan Blanchard I'm from Long
Island, New York, an undergrad
at MIT, and I'm studying
materials science and
engineering.
UROP stands for Undergraduate
Research
Opportunities Program.
They are really giving you the
resources to put any idea down
on the table and experiment
with it.
I open up literature and I read,
and I'm just like,
you know if I take A, B, and
C, and I put them together?
Do you think this could work?
They are just like I don't know,
let's just try it out
and see what's happening
and it's something new.
It's something, that when you
think about it, is something
that's your own too.
So, that's really what
makes it fun.
I wanted to do something in
regards to the energy problem.
With alternative energy sources,
like solar and wind,
they're intermittent.
When there's lots of sun, and
you have a storage device to
store that energy, and give
it to you when there's
not a lot of sun, then
you can make this a
feasible energy solution.
But the thing now is the storage
devices we have, like
lithium ion, they're incredibly
expensive.
So it's almost $1,000 per
kilowatt hour in some cases.
You need a device that's $100
per kilowatt hour, so that's
10 times cheaper to make this
a feasible concept.
So the liquid metal battery.
The key concept behind this is
you're going to have three
layers, all in the
liquid state.
You're going to have on the
bottom a dense metal.
The layer in the middle,
that's the molten salt.
And then, the top layer
is the light metal.
The beauty behind the entire
system really is that you can
put them all in the same cell,
heat them up, and they're
going to assemble by their
relative densities of each of
these components.
What I've been working on is
making the battery more
robust, more efficient.
I'm exploring just new
chemistries in general.
When you have all the components
ready, you take the
cell, and this is where you
do a lot of your work.
It's full with argon.
And argon is an inert gas, so
you get really accurate
results, and also, you make sure
that you're safe because
nothing really explodes
in this environment.
However, there is some
drawbacks, in the sense that
When you're working with the
gloves here it takes about two
to three times longer
to do any process.
We tried to use an entirely new
category of electrolytes.
We were really lucky to get
some really great data.
And now, we're trying to push
it even further to see if we
can increase the capacity
in a multitude of ways.
We developed something that
is close to $100 per
kilowatt hour now.
So it's bringing in the
alternative energy sources and
also it's going to allow the
grid to be a lot more energy
efficient, so it's cutting
on both regimes.
And when you see that come
together, that's like a pretty
amazing feat.
With this new device, it's going
to spark a new economy,
because private homes could even
store energy at night and
sell it back to the grid
the next morning.
I think a lot of the consistency
that's been in my
undergraduate experience has
been in research and getting
the skills to learn
how to solve new
and challenging problems.